[Music]
you've had these amazing experiences and
I want to hear about them for example
you had a very long and close
relationship with Prince and of course
his death you know so many people
talking about it but I haven't known
that many people who actually knew him
that well
and and and you knew him quite well I
did I was blessed one of the highlights
of my life was to know him we had a
20-year friendship which was quite
unlikely because the first time he calls
me Saturday morning early phone ring and
you were obviously you were known you
know television personality and things I
yeah and you're in the phone rings phone
rings on Saturday morning and he says
master Khattab as I said this is Tavis I
said who's calling he said Prince
I said who Prince click I hang up
you know coz he calls back a second time
on a Saturday morning
he says Tavis it's it's it's me Prince
mister managed to early on Saturday
morning don't play these games with me
click second time I think up all right
third time he calls back I hang up again
right he calls back finally says dude
hold up hold up hold up hold up this is
me it's Prince I'm in LA I'm at this
hotel here's the number
call the number ask for me by name I
will have them put the call through and
now I'm thinking oh shoot yeah have our
business in PBS you can go crazy frankly
you could be naked right work our way
out yes I'm thinking have I really hung
up on Prince three times I call and sure
enough it's him he wants to invite me to
lunch he's been watching this show to
your point and has decided he wants to
come on but I don't realize until weeks
later Handy's that he's really
interviewing me I got played by Prince
right he want to spend time with me over
lunch to see if he'd be comfortable
sitting next to me on national
television so it turns out that he
became friends and for 20 years you can
best believe I was profusely apologizing
for hanging up on him he'd never let me
forget it for 20 years
yeah to be honest the first two calls
were me pretending to be Prince total
princesses then he calls I've been
played by you - yeah
it's not this would be funny yeah what's
fasting is it I had the pleasure to meet
him I want to say I think I met him once
yeah and and didn't really at all get to
know him was backstage at a concert and
we were both watching the concert
together and I will say this he's the
best air drummer I've seen in my life
yeah he was he was air drumming along
and I've told this story before but he's
ever been along and hitting every and a
lot of people air drum he was playing
real drums that were invisible and it
was amazing most folk don't know he
starts out he starts out as a drummer
yeah and because he wanted to be better
than his father at his instrument on all
instruments he learned to play
everything you know that early prints
albums were like lead vocals prints
background vocals prints all instruments
played by prints album cover design
photo of prints taken by prints I did
everything yeah he was a great
autonomous sort of artist
you